good morning hank it's tuesday i've been
thinking a lot about this live it's
proven very durable on the internet and
yes i know the internet is made out of
lies but i find this one particularly
interesting
by the way head over to petesmas.com
before all this pizzamas stuff
disappears forever okay so i wrote about
this live from my podcast the
anthropocene reviewed but the lie turns
out to be even more interesting and
false than i originally understood it to
be the ligos like this
years ago the anthropologist margaret
mead was asked by a student what she
thought was the first sign of
civilization in a culture
the student expected mead to talk about
fish hooks or clay pots or grinding
stones but no
mead said the first sign of civilization
in an ancient culture was a femur that
had been broken
and then healed meat explained that in
the animal kingdom if you break your leg
you die a broken femur that has healed
is evidence that someone has taken time
to stay with the one who fell has bound
up the wound has carried the person to
safety and has tended the person through
recovery
helping someone through difficulty is
where civilization
starts in the last six months this has
become probably the most famous margaret
mead quote despite the fact that there's
no evidence she ever actually said it it
has been shared
millions of times including in one
recent case by a user who wrote i fact
checked and it's legit
but just to actually fact-check putting
aside the made-upness of the entire
story as the bio-archaeologist stacey
hackner has pointed out it's just not
true that animals never survived broken
femurs long enough to heal
in fact one review of such fractures and
primates found the healed fracture rate
higher than expected
also it's just not true that healed
femoral fractures are a marker of
civilization definitions of civilization
are inherently fraught but they tend to
focus on things like systems of writing
and concentrations of state power when
margaret mead actually sought to define
civilization she said
it means keeping accounts keeping
records it means some kind of taxation
and revenue it means a great deal of
division of labor what civilization does
not mean
is healed femoral fractures we know this
because there are many
many examples of healed femoral
fractures among humans who lived in
non-civilizational societies
also surviving a femoral fracture was
not particularly common
in civilizations like as recently as the
start of world war 1
most people who suffered femoral
fractures died and whether you survived
was largely down to whether you happen
to live near a good bone setter a role
that has been around for
many thousands of years and lots of
different human communities both those
with
and without systems of writing and
taxation so it's a lie the whole thing
is a lie but i think maybe the reason
the lie
is so seductive is that at its core
there is something true
many of us have been taught that only
the strong survive that life on earth is
about the powerful doing what they want
and the weak suffering what they must as
the athenians put it millennia ago
but in fact the human project as a whole
becomes much stronger when we do a
better job of protecting the vulnerable
and
affording all people the same rights
like we didn't get good at healing
femoral fractures by believing that the
strong do what they want and the weak
suffer what they must we got good at
healing femoral fractures because humans
have a capacity to understand
that serious illness or injury does not
negate the value of a human life
civilization gave us a system of writing
that allows us to compare best practices
for bone setting
across wide expanses of time and space
and civilization gave us the kind of
complex
tools that allow us to heal bones better
but civilization did not give us
compassion or empathy or self-sacrifice
all of which are values that pre-date
human civilization and in fact values
that
are not limited to humans maybe we need
to believe this lie that civilization is
where human compassion
and healing begin but i think the truth
is actually more beautiful and
ultimately
more encouraging all kinds of people
in all kinds of times have found ways to
help
and value one another hank i'll see you
tomorrow